caught up in a couple Saturdays from now
at the newly revamped pain arena in
McAllen Texas the combate America
winner-take-all showdown between Tito
Ortiz and Alberto el patron Rodriguez
will go down and Sue my right is a man
who's been now Wow seven years in the
UFC Hall of Fame Tito Ortiz good to see
you sir
thank you much you got it I gotta be
honest with you I don't say this to me
yes you look you look great thank you I
take care of myself yeah I've got I've
been in camp now for 17 weeks I got two
more hard weeks actually this one week
and then one more hard week and then
it's just cutting away getting down to
210 pounds and competing on Saturday
night December 7 how many surgeries have
you had I've had eight surgeries to date
hopefully I don't have to have any more
okay why did I see all my left knee
replacement 2003 I've done ISA replaced
my right knee 50% meniscus taking on my
right knee l4 5s one fused my lower back
t3 t2 t2 t1 t1 c7 disc replacement in
2017 and then c7 c6 fuse C 65 fused and
C 5 c4 disc replacement and a reattach
retina my left eye okay so I'm like I'm
like a Timex watch I keep on taking keep
looking keep on tickin or like the
operation guy yeah you've heard of so I
asked this with the ultimate respect
what the hell are you still doing fine
mom for fun for the fun of it I love it
I love competing and I love putting
myself through the grind I love seeing
the end result of course you know at 45
years old and yeah you're as young I
would say yes and still have an
eight-pack be in great shape you know my
kids they do wrestling and jiu-jitsu
also right and I want to show him what
hard work is how old are they I have
twin 10 year olds Jesse and Ernie that
I'm my oldest who's 17 Jacob and he
wrestles in high school themselves okay
but they see the hard work that does and
I just wanted to want them to understand
what hard work and dedication trailer
about and they see the training that I
do and they put the same effort and work
into school you know and it's important
you know I push education is really a
big part of my house
push you know they read an hour a day
five days a week
education number one that DMV says
that's a mandatory in our home that's
that's excellent I mean that's fantastic
and obviously you sticking with it in
doing that but are they concerned when
Dad gets hit I'm very thankful that you
know through my career of 22 years I've
I've only been dropped twice and you
know never been unconscious ever and
I've had probably about maybe six or
seven lacerations that's just been mere
flesh wounds the surgeries has happened
prior I'm in camps okay but um I've I
bet kept my wet about myself you know I
think being a wrestler you know domme in
a position of being on top has kept my
career with the longevity I think of not
wanting to stand and trade with guys a
lot of boxers they take a lot of abuse
I've just punches just the contusions
that they take to the head the blunt
force of the gloves people think of
gloves they're to protect a person's
face now its protect their hand and
that's it and you're still getting blows
to the head where it's uh
concussions come along and so forth but
you know I've been able to take care of
my my brain my body to a great enough
level that I'm still able to compete
it's fun but it's uh like I said I like
to see it was at the end of the rainbow
when I'm done there every fight before
the fight is just at my age I want to
show people that there's never too late
to do something you're able to do it no
matter what surgery has gone through
what hard things he times you go through
to make things that you love to do I
mean interesting and fun Tito Ortiz here
on the Rich Eisen show I mean we are
seeing it in the NFL right now at Tom
Brady age forty a zoo well I mean the
thing is you could see and you know
based on his career that he loves doing
what he's doing he loves the competition
but he also loves that hey I do this I
don't think another 42 year olds gonna
do it I'm gonna set that bar very high
it's just another bar to set it's just a
greedy way to look at it but you have to
be in that regard well I mean as any
professional athlete is it was agreed
more just being about only yourself you
know I got to be selfish there's times I
had to be so
but when it's time to be giving towards
your family there's time for that also
but there is a time for every man just
to be selfish and to think about himself
for his future I want to make sure I
have a nest egg for my kids when they
get older you know I was a kid who came
from nothing my mother and father had a
drug problem my mother got sober when I
was 13 she gave me a second um second
chance at life I think I got remarried
and my dad was really wasn't there for
me and I'm able to do the things my
father never was able to do and that's
be there for my my kids loving my kids
and I think it was just something that
he was never taught and I had to teach
to myself so I'm able to make the same
decision for my kids you know my twin
boys Jesse and journey I'm able to give
them everything they never had as what I
had was a kid so my oldest son Jacob
actually lives with his mother in
Arizona and she does an amazing job with
him
he's a smart gentleman awesome kid hard
hard worker but I I I really kind of
think with my twin boys they're all
under of my hands so under my thumb and
I make sure I just do the right things
Tito we're respectful it's respectful
kids open doors for girls and yes sir no
sir
looks someone in there and their eyes
are they shake hands and just be
respectful men Tito Ortiz here on the
Rich Eisen show your fellow Hall of Fame
fellow hall-of-famer Ken Shamrock did
make that Tom Brady reference in regards
to you are you really know that I'm a
huge fan of put Tom Brady I'm actually
Steven Neill who was on the offensive
line so I think that's why I Steve I'm
Tom Brady's career has been gone so well
his offensive line always potato yeah
that's his glove yeah that's his clothes
you know up front to protect his to
protect his hand who is the toughest
fighter you've ever toughest fighter
I've ever faced it has be Randy Couture
he took my world tide away from me back
in 2003 I was 30 years old I felt like I
was invincible and he out wrestled me
and just beat me round after round and I
thought the world was over I thought
everything was done I would never be a
fighter again and
but it just shows without character I am
i bounce back and still competing who
did you love talking crap about the most
Ken Shamrock cutouts it that was real
that was the guy who called you Brady
but you know I think there's one of
those kind of ideas and I think you know
it happens at all schools and high
schools when kids fight each other they
end up being best friends at the other
day okay because they you know they hash
out their problems by putting their
dukes up right and me and Ken Shamrock
it was a hate it was a true hate it was
nothing built upon there was no fakeness
about it at all and I we battled out
three times and all three times I got my
hand raised but he pushed me every
single time we compete against each
other I always thought that I was
fighting the world's most dangerous man
and I had to be the world's most
dangerous man and that's how I got my
hand raised yeah Wow and then who's the
guy you talk smack with the most didn't
you don't think deserve to return it to
you um what do mean it doesn't we dead
you you you talk smack and they return
it to you and you didn't think that
person deserved to actually talk smack
back to ah God Chael Sonnen a guy he
just I disliked that man he's he's just
something else someone who just talks
and talks and talks and has never done
anything in the sport besides talk well
it's what he does for a living now too
right yeah that's what he does for a
living
um he should have stayed to that and I
guess he is staying to it and he's
retired now so but he said some very
personal things about me and I'm a I'm a
very emotional man I'm a very loyal men
and when you talk about a person's
family I take it to heart and it's my
blood and I kind of let him have a
little bit of people I get an
opportunity to go on youtube and watch
Tito Ortiz uncaged he said a little
couple things about meetings talking
about me me but not my championship belt
and I had to let him have it full board
it wasn't just a little it was full
board I put him out for what who he
really was um he never said another word
about me Tito Ortiz here on the Rich
Eisen show and now you're doing what
many fighters are doing as well which is
broadening out branching out is this
your first film performance you know
this is like my
eight film I've done Wow okay uh back
then a lot of smaller films you know I
never actually had one opportunity to a
big film it was a cradle to the grave
with Jet Li and DMX and this was in 2003
my little champion
okay um and I sat there and watch him go
cut all right and action
cut all right and action cut over I was
like they get this many chances to do
this and they just I was like you know
I'm a perfectionist and if I'm able to
do that that many times I want to learn
this well I mean doing what you do for a
regular living I mean it's a one take
artist there's no there's no second
third takes well you did that in
training you know I think okay a
regional training group I'm sure camp of
this camp I pad for this fight has been
17 weeks and I got two more a week and a
half left but it's just having the
dedication have the dedication and
giving herself out and some that I've
learned over the last few years is when
Johnson is is being willing to expose
yourself and not being afraid to fail
and that's been a hard thing for me
because I I always wanted to be
successful and everything I do sort of
fell and to let myself out and open and
be vulnerable yeah um it's kind but I
think over the last year I've kind of
accepted it and I've learned it and it's
it's a trait to learn the acting skills
but dwayne johnson someone I really look
up to he's made the transition there I'm
a professional wrestling into acting I
mean he's a blockbuster he's the number
one star on planet earth right now you
won't make that a long long time that
guy is an amazing hard-working man that
I inspired to be I'm personal I look up
to for sure
well trauma center is the name of this
film that comes out in theaters on
demand Friday December 6th Bruce Willis
yes is in this yes you know he played a
fighter in Pulp Fiction
yep you know yeah who let pride mess
with his mind
according to Marcellus Lewis ages it's
crazy I just I seen him I was like you
look exactly look like 20 years ago
what'd he say yeah he was think he's all
you're a really big guy yeah he was cool
he was a very calm mellow mannered man
very respectful okay you know it was
cool first time I ever met him I was
kind of starstruck myself but those
cools Bruce Willis
yeah but in the film actually Mickey
Waylon who plays Madison guess who the
girl I chase around the hospital we're
seeing it right here you said you have
not seen this footage before this is you
chasing around Niki Whelan right now in
a stairwell and yes throughout my entire
take this battle hum we chase it chase
her around this hospital hum and up
shooting myself by accident spoiler
alert it's very alert let me tell you
this this film took a little bit out of
me hum there's you know a part of the
film that I have to grab her and be very
hands-on and yes it's kind of scared me
a little bit I'm just uh
I like I've got off set and I kind of I
just had to take a set to secta myself
but just like okay that was just your
character that was just just right yeah
and so did you go to a place where you
treated her like she was Chael Sonnen is
that what you're saying yeah only got
ahold of her home
look you guys watch people have to see
this again and theaters and on demand
Friday December 6 and what's gonna
happen on Saturday December 7th big
weekend for you got a movie coming out
Friday and then this fight on Saturday
yeah you know and that's another great
thing is the movie got shot way before
this fight was announced so and I got it
done then all of a sudden I just got
through camp I've been killing myself in
camp getting ready for to put on a show
you know I've done every single one of
my fights I think this kind of would be
a little bit of National Geographic of a
lion hasn't eaten for a year and he's
gonna get that little gazelle he's been
chasing my gazelles a little real it's
not gonna cage with an animal and this
war this lion hasn't eaten in a year and
right every time to roar what an
interesting way to put it for sure again
so if you win you take physical
possession of el patron s WWE title gasp
this is my idea and work took the hook
line and sinker I was very happy I'm a
huge dub dubby fan
WWF back in the day sure Hogan this guy
yeah icons I love and I know he was was
a heavyweight world champion Alberto Del
Rio and I was like I wonder if I put up
one of my light heavyweight belts on the
line would he put his head way about the
line you know my kids at just so you
know there are huge W fans they were
sitting right here they can name every
one of the guys on the Ross
okay and I told them about it they're
like dad would you really put up on your
belts for it now yeah yeah let's do it
so I did it and he bid it hook line and
sinker so on December 7th live on
pay-per-view as I beat him yes my kids
be walking down with me into the fight
I'm bringing them there to the fight
this the first time ever both them will
be there all three of my boys walk down
with me into the fight and I'm gonna put
it around their shoulder when I take it
from there you go you're getting el
patrones WWE title belt
you're putting your UFC one of them
light heavyweight championship belts on
the line it'll be Saturday December 7th
pain arena in McAllen Texas if you there
go there if not pay-per-view good to see
you sir thanks for coming on your time
thinking you've got that's Tito Ortiz at
Tito Ortiz on twitter and at Tito Ortiz
1999 on instagram for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app